the dramatic development in the search
for a suspect and a leak of the highly
sensitive sensitive Pentagon documents
FBI agents arrested a 21-year-old Heir
National Guardsman his name is Jack
Tashara at his home in Massachusetts
that's him hands on his head in the red
shorts there the case is Raising serious
questions about how something like this
could happen and also remain undetected
for months senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge is at
the Pentagon Forest Catherine as of
Monday they had no idea where these
documents were coming from now Friday
they have an arrest good morning
Good morning Tony the suspect has an
initial appearance in the Boston Court a
short time from now after fast moving
events Thursday culminated in his arrest
news crews captured the arrest live
showing heavily armed federal agents
taking the suspect into custody Thursday
outside his mother's home south of
Boston the suspect is identified as
Massachusetts Air National Guardsman
Jack Tashara he's accused of leaking
hundreds of pages of classified military
documents and CIA updates including on
the war in Ukraine some revealing how
the U.S gathers Intelligence on both
allies and adversaries clearly there was
harm done former Secretary of Defense
Mark esper told CBS news that the
security questions are Urgent you can't
think of a good reason for a 21 year old
to have access to this information no I
I cannot think of a compelling reason
and I assume uh secretary Austin and
chairman The Joint Chiefs Miller are
probably asking those same questions
Tashira installed fiber optic cable and
that Tech job may have allowed him to
monitor networks through which
classified intelligence flowed this was
a deliberate criminal act the Pentagon
first discovered highly classified
material posted on social media a week
ago though the leak apparently began
late last year when the documents
surfaced in a chat group on the gaming
platform Discord President Biden was
briefed Thursday evening about the
arrest and commented earlier Thursday
during his visit to Ireland I'm
concerned that it happened but there's
nothing contemporaneous that I'm aware
of that is
wildly embarrassing democratic
congresswoman Abigail spanberger a
former CIA officer who now sits on the
house intelligence committee said the
records posted online are revealing
we'll never be able to pull all of that
information back from the internet wiped
from a place where our adversaries will
be able to see it
after the arrest defense secretary
Austin ordered an investigation into how
the highly classified material
circulated online for months without the
Pentagon detecting it Tashara was
arrested in connection with the alleged
unauthorized removal retention and
transmission of classified defense
information his lawyer is not commenting
at this time Dana
all right Catherine still so many
questions out there thank you